we're about to play let's make a deal to
hopefully win some money for these
puppies from wagmore pets a dog rescue
and you have a very special connection
with wagmore i do my latest
lord chesterfield was rescued from
wagmore well everyone knows that i love
a game show and who doesn't what better
way to kick off los angeles week than a
classic game show let's make a deal
so everybody welcome wayne brady
no it could be yours though no i already
got four i already have four hey y'all
all right wayne thank you for honoring
us with your presents what was my
pleasure i just visited you and your
premier week yes ma'am so thank you for
coming today tell us what we are playing
for all right so if you know let's make
a deal you know that we love to make a
deal of course so we're going to play a
game called how much is enough
now easy-peasy game this first prize
that you're playing for it is
a picture of us on the set of let's make
a deal now do you keep this picture as
amazing as it is and just walk away it's
yours or do you take a silver envelope
and that silver envelope will be brought
into me by the money fairy aka chris
ahern one of our producers thank you
money fairy
uh with all due respect to both of us i
think i'm gonna go with the silver yeah
super envelope now you know this could
be a zonk a zonk but it isn't it's 25
000. oh my god
so you've got 25 000
for wag more
now you can keep your 25 000
and your picture and just walk away
or you could take this gold envelope
if
if you decide to take the gold envelope
and there's a zonk inside then you lose
everything
remember when i said that if this was a
zonk you'd lose it yes we remember okay
i just got to reiterate i know
another twenty-five thousand dollars
another twenty-five thousand dollars to
wagmore you now have fifty thousand
dollars
plus the picture
which i'm so happy that you get that
because i'm a dog dad i've got four dogs
gay wagons
money fairy the big envelope please
[Music]
thank you
if this is a zonk you lose everything so
you can walk away right now with your 50
grand remember we talked about not
wanting to be greedy and not being
ambitious i think we stick we're the
ones i do too
so you're passing on the envelope oh
come on
oh my goodness yes you guys have shot
films all all over the world have you
ever shot in hungary
no
no he hates the idea and i'm hungarian
okay
because what you passed on
this is a zonk
and
little known that zonk is actually the
hungarian translation of he's just not
that into you
so
congratulations you missed out on a zomb
let's hear it for wagmore
miss anderson drew thank you so much
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much that's fifty thousand
dollars and fifty thousand dollars is
amazing
you just by the way come on don't pee on
me baby
i think it it's good um all right that's
fifty thousand dollars and it'll go
towards wag more pets dog rescue
which
jennifer aniston has brought to the
forefront of our attention it's an
extraordinary organization right here
but you can support it from all across
the country we want to send a huge thank
you
to the wildest your go to pet parent
site and pet dna decoder wisdom panel
for your donations and supporting
wagmore pets dog rescue
those are the two companies that gave us
the 25 thousand dollars yay
and thank you so much for supporting
wagamore go to the drewberrymore
show.com to find out more information on
the wildest wisdom panel and wag more
pets dog rescue and wayne thank you so
much for doing this thanks for having me
pleasure to see you be sure to check out
let's make a deal today on cbs
the morning show premieres september
17th on apple tv
[Music]